[موسيقى]
السودان على مفترق طرق يعاني ازمه
اقتصاديه خانقه تدفع بالملايين من ابنائه
الى دائره الفقر وحتى الجوع ويغرق ساسته
ونخبه العسكريه في انقسامات لا قرار لها
كما يبدو تصعدت منذ قرر الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في اكتوبر من العام الماضي
الغاء الشراكه بين المدنيين والعسكريين
التي اسست لمرحله الانتقاليه بعد عزل
الرئيس عمر البشير غير ان البرهان نفسه
عاد بعد قرابه ثمانيه اشهر ليتعهد بخروج
القوات المسلحه من العمليه السياسيه
وتسليم السلطه الى حكومه مدنيه بلا مخصصه
يتولى الجيش حرارتها ثم ليتحدث عن وطنيه
لمسها لدى شركائه السابقين في قوى الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي وليكشف طاووس
واقليون عن التوصل الى ما وصفه بتفهمات
اساسيه بين العسكريين والمدني من جانبه
اكد المجلس المركزي لقوى الحريه والتغيير
عدم التوقيع على اتفاق النهائي دون موافقه
جميع القوى الثوريه ورقم هذا ظهرت
انقسامات وخلافات مستقى فقد رفضت عده
احزاب منها حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي الاصل
والحزب الشيوعي والحزب البعثه العربيه
الاشتراكي منطقه تسويه الثنائيه بدفع من
هو محليه وخارجيه وفقا بياناتهم
وتصريحاتهم
في قصتنا الليله السودان البحث عن
الديمقراطيه نرصد المسار السياسي في
السودان منذ عام 2019 والازمات التي رافقت
المرحله الانتقاليه مرورا برصد ملابسات
انهاء الشراكه بين العسكريين والمدنيين
نعرض الانقسامات في توصيف ما جرى وسبل
تجاوز ما تعانيه البلاد نستكمل بقيه القصه
مع الصديق الصادق المهدي مساعد رئيس حزب
الامه المنطقه الرسميه باسم المجلس
المركزي للحريه والتغيير والفريق اول فتح
الرحمن محي الدين القائد العام الاسبق
للقوات البحريه السودانيه
الى تسويه سياسيه جديده تنقل الحكم في
السودان الى سلطه مدنيه الانتقاليه وعن
ضمانات السعاده الثقه بين المدنيين
والعسكريين وفرص يتجاوز الانقسامات
والاصوات التي اعلنت رفضها هذه التسويه
حتى قبل احتمالها
تاثير الدوري الاقليمي والدولي في صياغه
الوضع في السودان لكن لمشاهد القصه ونبدا
بعدها الحوار
[موسيقى]
بعد نجاح الثوره باسقاط حكم البشير في
ابريل 2019
توافقت قوى الحريه والتغيير مع المؤسسه
العسكريه لتوقيع اتفاقيه عرفت بالوثيقه
الدستوريه تقضي بتقاسم السلطه لمده ثلاث
سنوات وانشاء مجلس سياده يدير المرحله
الانتقاليه بالاضافه الى تعيين الدكتور
عبد الله حمدوك رئيسا للحكومه الجديده
على الرغم من تحقيق الحكومه بعض الانجازات
المهمه لم تسر مجريات الامور بمشتهت احلام
الثوره فسرعان ما تازم الواقع السياسي في
السودان
وتضاربت مواقف الشركاء وهو ما اشار اليه
رئيس الوزراء انذاك عبد الله حمدوك في
مبادراته الموسومه بالازمه الوطنيه وقضايا
الانتقال الطريق للامام في الثاني
والعشرين من يونيو عام 2021 حيث يقول
شهيده الفتره الماضيه تصعد الخلاف بين
شركاء الفتره الانتقاليه مما يشكل خطرا
جديا لا على الفتره الانتقاليه فحسب بل
على وجود السوداني نفسه وقد بذلت مجهودات
في التواصل مع الاطراف المختلفه ونزع فتيل
الازمه والتي ارى انها لن تحل الا في اطار
تسويه سياسيه شامله
عندنا اختلافات كثيره جدا في النهايه تضحك
يعني جاءت الخصومات السياسيه وجاد تنافس
السياسي واذا عدم الثقه بين المكونين
العسكري والمدني ودي كلها تناقضات من
الداء من داخل الشراكه المهم من الخارج
فيما يتعلق ب ااا جبهه المعارضه همم
التجربه السودانيه اكدت انه هو السياسيه
السودانيه
بطبيعه تكوينه وباخبراته اغدا تتميز في في
في في رواها او في تقديراتها
كما اكدت التجربه السودانيه انه الوحده
التي ندعو لها ونعمل في سبيله هي ليست
وحده مطلقه حينما سقط البشير لم تكن كل
الغوص سياسيه موحده ال ال الوحده تبقى في
اطار الوحده الممكنه وفي اطار اوسع جبهه
وتشكيله اذا ما تم حتى الان لا يعني عدم
تشكيله
لم تاتي مبادره رئيس الوزراء عبد الله
حمدوك ثمارها في تخفيف الازمه التي بدات
تلقي بظلالها اذ وقعت مجموعه من الاحداث
التي عقدت المشهد اكثر فاكثر ففي الحاد
والعشرين من سبتمبر عام 2020 تم الاعلان
عن محاوله انقلاب غامضه لم تعرف الجهه
التي كانت وراءها
وفي الثاني من اكتوبر عام 2021 حدث انشقاق
داخل تحالف الحريه والتغيير نتج عنه ظهور
جسم جديد جسم الحريه والتغيير التوافق
الوطني الذي يضم مجموعه من الحركات
المسلحه وابرزها حركه العدل والمساواه
وحركه جيش تحرير السودان بينما اطلق على
المجموعه الاخرى اسم الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي وكانت تضم حزب الامه
القومي وحزب المؤتمر السوداني وحزب البعث
العربي الاشتراكي والتجمع الاتحادي كما
تحضر في الساحه مكونات سياسيه ومدنيه اخرى
ليست جزء من تحالف الحريه والتغيير مثل
لجان المقاومه والمؤتمر الشعبي والحزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي الاصل والحزب الشيوعي
السوداني وتحالف القوه الوطنيه
هذه الازمه ليست وليده اليوم ولم تهبط
علينا من السماء ولم تفاجئنا البته نتيجه
لتتابع الازمات التي خيمت على المشهد
السياسي في السودان القى رئيس الوزراء
انذاك عبد الله حمدوك خطابا حول الوضع
السياسي الراهن وقال ان هذه الازمه التي
تعيشها البلاد ليست وليده اليوم وجوهرها
هو تعذر الاتفاق على مشروع وطني متوافق
عليه بين قوه الثوره والتغيير هذا التعذر
ياتي نسبه لانقسامات عميقه وسط المدنيين
ووسط العسكريين وبين المدنيين والعسكريين
والتغيير
الى مستوى النظم السياسيه بيتعرف عليها
والتعامل الفيحياديه
لكل من يجب ان يقوم بها بصوره متكامله
وليس في شكل اقصاء او ازاله لبعضنا البعض
او احلال او ابداعات
الثوره تقرر الاتي اعلان حاله الطوارئ في
جميع انحاء البلاد وفي سياق مستمر لتفاكم
كافه الازمات المتراكمه انها قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان في الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر عام 2021
الشراكه بين المجلس العسكري وقوه الحريه
والتغيير لاداره المرحله الانتقاليه
[موسيقى]
واعلن لكم
استقالتي من منصب رئيس الوزراء
[موسيقى]
عليهم انطلاق يقوم على حكومه منتخبه دائره
تفويض عسكري والعسكريين يكونوا موجودين في
السكنات او في في معسكرتهم ولكن المدنيين
في تسعه ابريل 2019 او اقصص 2019
كل مواطن سوداني ان هذا انقلاب لو هو حتى
هم اشد متمسكين كانوا بكلمه همم فضشيراكه
وينه لا تعني شيء انه مؤكد انه ليس انقلاب
هم نفسهم اصبح يقولوا ادعونا لا لا نختلف
حول التسميات
25 اكتوبر 25 اكتوبر
منتصوري قرارات البرهان في اكتوبر عام
2021 تصاعدت الاحداث بشكل مستمر
[تصفيق]
فشهده البلاد احتجاجات كثيره واعلانات لا
تنقطع عن مليونيات تجوب طرقات البلاد
واسفرت الاحتجاجات الشعبيه على قرارات
الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر عن نحو مئه
وسبعه عشر قتيلا 69 منهم قتلوا برصاص حي
مباشر بحسب لجنه اطباء السودان المركزيه
في ما اعتقلت قوات الامن السودانيه قرابه
الف شخص اضافه لاخفاء ال 10 قصرا في اطار
الحمله الموسعه على معارض قرارات الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر وفقا
اكبر حاجه 25 اكتوبر هم الشهداء الراحم
ضحيه خلفي مجابهه الانقلاب ده ده بيدور
عليه انه السلطه ولا الجنرالات الجامبو
يعني جاهزين النوم
[تصفيق]
ين همم
بدون
شكر للاسف الشديد همم يعني تم استشهاد بعض
الشباب ولكن اذا ارادوا ان يسهم كبيرا في
هذه اداره المرحله الانتقاليه في العمليه
السياسيه
او فعاليات سياسيه
[موسيقى]
نتيجه لحل الحكومه المدنيه في اكتوبر 2021
توقفت العديد من المنح والاعفاءات التي
كانت مقرره للسودان من ضمنها 700 مليون
دولار امريكي مساعدات امريكيه بحسب معهد
الولايات المتحده للسلام بالاضافه الى
تجميد ما تقدمت به مبادره هيبك التي
اطلقها البنك الدولي وصندوق النقد الدولي
التي كان من شانها تخفيف اعضاء الدين
الخارجي للسودان ما نسبته 90% من مجموع
الدين الخارجي بحسب البيان الصحفي لصندوق
النقد الدولي في يونيو 2001 2020
[موسيقى]
هناك ردي اقتصادي مريء ومخيف فقد السودان
اكبر اعفاء للديون في تاريخ المؤسسات
الاقتصاديه الدوليه بعد ان تجاوزنا حاجز
منتصف يونيو دون ان نتمكن او نفلح في ان
نقيم حكومه مدنيه تكون مقنعه للشعب
السوداني اولا ليقتنع بها العالم من حولنا
ويدعم
ويقوم بوفاء بالتزامات
صعب
اكثر مما
نتفعوا دوله ضعيفه يعني هذا امر لا يستقيم
في سياسه الدوليه في العالم فاا يعني كونه
دخلونا في ظلمونا فوز الارض الله واسعه في
هذا العالم
[موسيقى]
حصل تباين في التعاطي مع المجلس العسكري
وقراراته في السودان انعكس بشكل سلبي على
القوه المدنيه والثوريه واصبح هناك صراعا
محتدما بين المجلس العسكري ومناصره من
القوه المدنيه من جهه وبين قوه ثوريه
وسياسيه تقود حراكا احتجاجيا مستمرا في
البلاد ترفع شعار لا تفاوض ولا شركه ولا
شرعيه من جهه اخرى لتعصفه تلك الانقسامات
بايه امكانيه لتشكيل حكومه توافقيه تدير
الحكم في الفتره الانتقاليه
[موسيقى]
في صناعه 25 اكتوبر ولكن احنا متوافقين في
ما جاءت بقرار خاصه المثل الذي يخص مساله
التوافق الذي يهمنا كثيرا نحن
يتحدث عن وحده القوه المدنيه
لتشكيل حكومه
والسؤال الذي يطرح نفسه من الذي يعتمد
الحكومه
والسلطه لدى من
الفريق البرهان كما خبيرنا اييي ال ال
الغاده الانقلابيين في السودان
ااه يرغبون ويتشبسون بالسلطه
ويشرفون على حكومه
لتصريف الاعمار
تعتمر بامرتهم
منذ صدور قرارات ال 25 من اكتوبر 2021
انطلقت العديد من المبادرات الداخليه
والامميه والدوليه التي سعد الى ايجاد
ارضيه مشتركه وتفتح افقا لحوار فاعل ينهي
بواعث الازمه
واهم هذه المبادرات الاليه الثلاثيه التي
انطلقت في يناير 2022
والمكونه من بعثه الامم المتحده في
السودان بالاضافه الى الاتحاد الافريقي
ومنظمه الهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه في شرق
افريقيا اي ايجاد مبادره حزب الامه القومي
والتي انطلقت في مارس 2022 تهدف الى تشكيل
كتله ثوريه عريضه بهدف الجلوس مع المكون
العسكري والحوار الجاد حول العوده للمسار
المدني والديمقراطي مبادره نداء اهل
السودان اطلقاها الطيب الجد في يوني 2022
دعا من خلالها لحل الازمه السودانيه
المبادره الرباعيه التي طرحتها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالاضافه الى بريطانيا
والسعوديه والامارات حيث نجحت في جمع
المكون العسكري وقوه الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي في لقاء مباشر بمنزل
السفير السعودي في التاسع من يونيو 2022
وذلك للمره الاولى منذ قرارات الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر
صحيح ان في خلال الفترات اللي فاتت تحركت
بعد المجموعات هنالك الان يعني حسرت
المبادرات على المستوى السادس السياسيه
السودانيه الى
مبادرات من تعادل اصابع اليد ولكن ذلك لا
يعني بان
التوافق التامه لانه هناك تعاند من جهات
اخرى وخاصه من الحريه التغيير مجلس المذكر
المركزي الذي يرصد الجلوس مع الاخرين وحسب
بانهم
يسعون للسيطره على على الحكم انه هذا امر
من الصعوبه في مكان خاصه لان الوضع في
السودان الذي الان لا يتحمل لان السودان
الان في استقطاب همم في استقدام كثيرا جدا
جدا
كلها بيت شده الرغبه وشده الحرص على ان
يكون هناك مخرج همم لانه زمن لم يزعفنا
والان اهلنا بيعانوا من الامرين في
الفيضانات والسيول والغلاء والمشاكل
الصحيه وواضح انه الاثر بتاع انعدام او
عدم وجود دوله او حكومه متفق عليها
والمشاكل الاداريه واضح ان عندها دور كبير
جدا بجانب المشاكل الاخرى الاخرى الموروثه
[موسيقى]
عام للقوات المسلحه
الاتي اولا عدم مشاركه المؤسسه العسكريه
في المفاوضات الجاريه حاليا والتي تسهلها
الاهليه الثلاثيه
2020 اعلى قائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان انسحاب المؤسسه العسكريه من حوار
الاليه الثلاثيه داعيا القوه السياسيه
لتشكيل حكومه كفاءات وطنيه
وتعاهد بحل مجلس السياده بعد تشكيل حكومه
مدنيه
هنالك قوى مدنيه وسياسيه واجتماعيه مع
الانقلاب وشاركت فيه
وهنالك غوى سياسيه ومدنيه والتيارات
الرئيسيه السياسيه والفكريه بالبلاد اضافه
الى لجان المقاومه والتنظيمات الاخرى
ظلت تؤكد على رفضها للانقلاب وتواجه
وبكل التضحيات المطلوبه وبالتالي فرضيه
البرهان المستحيله لان يجمع بين هذين ال
ال الفريقين هي تاكيد على تشبه بالسلطه
باحتبار انه المستحيل اا لا يتحقق
عايزين العصر يمشي السكنات لكن قبل ما
يمشي يسلمه للصورتهم بالتحديد
يمكن العسكري يعني كامل الزكاه لحد ما ان
هو لبى مطالب بطريقه واضحه لكن بطريقه
اخرى يعني زي ما بيقولوا يعني ترك الكره
في ارض كل القوه السياسيه
القصه بتاعت النوم مكونات المدينه
دي نوع من ذاته لانه هو احنا عرفنا واحنا
نتوافق ولا هنتفق نهائي مع المكونات
وقاصد بعض المكونات اللي بتدعمه وهو عارف
لانه في نفس الخانه فيها
ما تزال الثوره السودانيه واقفه على مفترق
طرق امنه ان يكون الغد مشرقا تكمل فيه
طريقها لتحقيق الحريه والسلام والعداله
سياسيه معقده ترععها الاليه الثلاثيه
المكونه من بعثه الامم المتحده بالسودان
والاتحاد الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه
للتنميه الشرق افريقيا
ثم التوصل اليها بين العسكريين ومحاورين
من المجلس المركزي للقوه الحريه والتغيير
وقد حصلت شبكه الجزيره على اهم تعديلات
حيث هذه الوثيقه على ان جمهوريه السودان
هي دوله ديمقراطيه فيدراليه نظام الحكم
فيها نظام الامانيه وان السودان دوله
مدنيه تقف على مسافه واحده من كل الاديان
وكريم المعتقدات المسوده نصت ايضا على عدم
جواز اتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه بحق الشاغلي
المواقع القياديه العليا بالاجهزه
النظاميه بشان اي مخالفات قانونيه ثم
ارتكبها قبل توقيها دستور الانتقالي الا
انها قضت بتقديم منسوبي الاجهزه العسكريه
والامنيه الذين ارتكبوا جرائم مباشره
للعداله وكذا تمكين الاجهزه العدليه من
الوصول اليهم المسوده منصه ايضا على ازاله
التمر وتفكيك بنيتي نظامي 30 مليون
الامنيه والعسكريه وتقضي بان يقوم رئيس
الوزراء المدني
الشرطه والمخابرات العامه كما يتراسوا
مجلس نساء مجلسا للامن والدفاع
الجيش والدعم السريع هذه المسوده همم
مسوده الوثيقه ايضا نصت على انشائي جهاز
للامن داخلي تتبع له قوات الشرطه وكذا
انشاء المجلس العدليه المؤقت ومهمته تعيين
رئيس القضاء والنائب العام والرئيس
المحكمه الدستوريه وقضت بان مهمه القوات
المسلحه في الفتره الانتقاليه هي حمايه
الدستور والتصدي للمحاولات للانقلابيه
وتنفيذ السياسات المتعلقه بالاصلاح الامني
والعسكري وانشاء الجيش قوميا واحد المسوده
منصه ايضا على ان قوه الدعم السريع تتبع
للقوات المسلحه وتدمجه في الجيش ويكون راس
الدوله
مشاركه اعضاء المكونه العسكري في
الانتخابات التي
الفتره الانتقاليه
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مجددا المشاهدين
الكرامين من الخرطوم الصديق الصادق المهدي
مساعد رئيس حزب الامه والناطق باسم المجلس
المركزي للحريه والتغيير والفريق اول فتح
الرحمن محي الدين القائد العام السابق
للقوات البحريه السودانيه اهلا بضيفين
الكريمين على نبدا مع الفريق اول فتح
الرحمن محي الدين القائد العام السابق
للقوات البحريه السودانيه ولعلنا نبدا
السيد الفريق اول فتح الرحمن من هذه
الوثيقه التي تم تسريبها
والحقيقه نود ان نسال عن تكتم الشديد حول
هذه الوثيقه التي ذكر بانه تم التوافق
عليها او على الاقل يتم التفاوض بشانها
بين المكونين العسكري والمدني اليس من حق
السودانيين الاطلاع عليها بشكل رسمي
طيب التحيه لكم التحيه لساده متابعه
الجزيره والتحيه للضيفك الكريم السيد
الصديق الصادق المهدي حقيقه اعتقد انه
صيغه المحامين يعني منذ البدايه وجدت رفضا
شديدا من معظم القوى السياسيه في الساحه
تقبلتها فقط مركزيه الحريه والتغيير في
البدايه المكان العسكري في البدايه ايضا
ابدع عليها تحفظا و رفضا لكن بعد ان عرضت
عليه وادخل عليها تعديلات بما يحسن القوات
المسلحه ويضمن وحدتها وصيانتها وكل
التعديلات المطلوبه والاصلاحات المطلوبه
داخل القوات المسلحه تكون مسؤوليه تقوات
المسلحه همم وافقت القوات المسلحه او وافق
المكونه العسكري حقيقه على ان تكون هذه
الوثيقه مطروحه للتعديل ايضا من قبل القوى
السياسيه
التحكيم ياتي حقيقه من مركزيه الحريه
والتغيير ومن الاهليه الثلاثيه يعني كان
يجب عليهم
والان هنالك حديث عن ان هذه الوثيقه الان
لا زالت في طور التنجيح وفي طور التعديل
ومطروحه للقوه السياسيه لكي يبدو
ملاحظاتهم عليها حتى يتم التوافق عليها
اذا كان الامر كذلك انا اعتقد لا داعي
لهذا التكتيم يجي من تطرح هذه الوثيقه
ويجب على القوى السياسيه ايضا لا تمانع في
همم استلامه وتلقيحه وادخال ملاحظاتهم
عليها حتى تكون اساسا تنفيذ الفتره
الانتقاليه الى الامام
ترجعون الامر هنا اتوجه بالسؤال لضيف
الكريم السيد الصديق الى همم
المجلس المركزي للحريه والتغيير بما انك
ناطق باسمه نود ان نعرف لماذا هذا التعتيم
من قبالكم كما يقول ضيفنا اليس من حق
السودانيين الشعب السوداني ان يعرف مخرجات
ثورته الى اين ستقوده هذه الثوره
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الترحيب
بهذا البرنامج وبيض الكريم
بالمشاهدين
وفي حقيقه الامر
مساله الشفافيه مهمه جدا وطلب مشروع جدا
ويجب ان يحدث وهذا حقيقه ما قررناه ولكن
في حقيقه الامر همم الحريه والتغيير عندما
طلعت بهذه المهمه هي جزء من قوه الثوره
وليست كل قوه الثوره همم
ولكنها قالت على نفسها ان تجد حلولا وهذه
مهمه القوه السياسيه في كل بلد
ومهمتنا اطلعنا بها النجد حلا يحقق اهداف
الشعب السوداني يحقق اهداف ثوره الشعب
المجيده ولذلك تبنينا هذه الاهداف لانه ان
احنا تجوزوا من الثوره
وواحده من الاليات التي تم اعتمادها ان ان
نعمل على تحقيق هذه الاهداف
في الوسائل المختلفه بالضغط المدني واعمال
التصعيد المختلفه التي حقيقه منها كذلك
انكم كنتم رافضين جمله وتفصولا تفصيلا اي
تفاوض يعني ما الذي تغير لماذا تغيرتم
رايكم وذهبتم الى هذا التفاوض منفردين
هناك قوه كثيره مثل ما تقول وهي رافضه الى
حد الان اي شكل من اشكال التفاوض
همم استاذتي العزيزه منذ فبراير همم منذ
فبراير الماضي همم من العام 2022 اتمنى
تكون الحريه والتغيير همم الاليات الثلاثه
التي كنتم على يعني اتحدث عن الثاني منها
التواصل الدبلوماسي والثالثه العمليه
السياسيه والهذه تتاسس على الحوار متى ما
تاسس همم وجدت اسس لحوار مجدي يفضي
لسلطه مدنيه وتحقيق اهداف الثوره هذا
مشروعنا الذي بنيناه في الحريه والتغيير
ولذلك عندما بادره ال- ال- الوساطه عبر
الاليه الثلاثيه همم تجاوبنا معها قطعتين
ايجابا مع المبادره ولكن الاجتماع الذي
كانت له الثلاثيه في روتانا قدرنا انه لا
يمكن ان يحقق اهداف الثوره لانه ايه
اجتماع كان مغرقا بكثير من القوه الشموليه
التي شاركت النظام المضاد
والايدت انقلاب 25 اكتوبر ولذلك لم يكن
وهذا على حد تصريح السيد ولد لباد نفسه
الذي قال ان اا الذين اجتمعوا في روتانا
بدون حضور قوى الحريه والتغيير لا يمكنهم
تحقيق حل للمشكله والازمه السودانيه
وعندما تسهلت او الوساطه طرحت حوار مباشر
مع قاده المكونه العسكري همم بادرنا
بالمشاركه في هذا الحوار همم اجنده الثوره
بمشروع الثوره في مشروع الثوره المدنيه
يعني اطراف اصيله في هذه همم الثوره ليست
معكم الى حد الان صحيح انكم حملتم بتفاوض
نيابه عنها لكن من فوضكم في نهايه الامر
هناك اطراف مثل ما ذكرنا ترفض جمله
وتفصيلا همم اي همم حوار منها اللجان
الشعبيه مثلا ولاءاتها ثلاث يعني تقول لا
كلام مساومه ولا تفاوض ماذا عن هؤلاء
وانتم اكدتم انكم لن توقعوا ولن تمضوا في
اي تفاوض دون موافقه الجميع كيف تضمنون
مشاركه وموافقه الجميع معكم
همم نحن نزلنا كل الثوره ولكننا يجوز اصيل
من هو الثوره كما هن هناك كما هناك همم
جهات ومكونات اصيله في قوه الثوره
ولكن مهمه القوه السياسيه هي ايجاد مخرج
وايجاد حل يعني القوه الثوره والشارع يقدم
مطالب وهو يريد سلطه مدنيه يريد
تحقيق شعارات الثوره حريه سلام وعداله همم
لا يريد الشراكه ولا يريد الشرعيه وكذلك
لا يريد تفاوض لماذا لا تتفاوض هي اليه
تحددها القوه السياسيه ولذلك نحن الذين
حددنا الاليات كقوه سياسيه تبنين اهداف
الثوره واهداف الشارع
وحددنا الاليات التي راينا انها تحقق او
عمرها يتم تحقيق هذه الاهداف ولذلك كان
هذا الحوار
اما ما يلي مساله
تحديد الشفافيه نعم لان الذي الذي نطلع به
هو يهم الشعب السوداني يهم الثوره
السودانيه ولا يخص قوه الحريه والتغيير
للسيد الفريق اول فتح الرحمن محي الدين
يعني من اهم الامور التي طالب بها
السودانيين هي ضروره
محاكمه ومسائله ووضعهم امام مسؤولياتهم
وامام القضاء من يسمونهم بقتله الشعب
السوداني في هذه الوثيقه يعني لماذا تعطي
من اهم بنودها كما اطلعنا عليها المشاهد
الكريم بانها تعطي ضمانات ضد المساءله
والمحاسبه لشاغلي المواقع القياديه العليا
يعني الحصانه للكبار
والمحاكمه للصغار فقط
لا لا ابدا انا اعتقد انه يعني هذا النص
يعني 30 يعني مبتوره النص يقول ما لم يعني
ما لم يعني هذه الحصانه للمناسبه القياديه
ما لم يكون في هذا الامر اذا جسماني يقع
على اي جهه من الجهات اذا وقع اذى جسماني
بسبب الامتناع او بسبب الفعل الموضوع
لو قريت الناس كاملا يعني هنالك حصانه
العليا
ما لم يكون هنالك اذى جسماني وقع على اي
جهه اوفر اذا كان هنالك ازاء جسمالي يحاسب
من اتخذ هذا القرار يعني المبدا لا يوجد
افلات من العراق
متظاهر في الشارع وانا لا اعرف اين قتل
ومن الذي قتله وكيف قتل وتحملني انا
ومسؤوليته هذا هو المقصود لكن اي شخص يصدر
الامر او يتخذ غيره او يمتنع عن تنفيذ امر
يتسبب في اذى جسمان لاي شخص هذا الشخص
انا مكاننتي
النقطه الاساسيه يا عزيزتي في في هذا
الموضوع
مركزيه الحريه والتغيير للاسف يعني حتى
الان لم تغير خطابه الخطاب الذي تتخاطب به
مع ضغيت القوه السياسيه في كثير من
التعالي في كثير من الناحيه اساس اردنيه
قبلت بالجلوس همم مع همم الطرف الاخر مع
العسكريين ومفاوضاتهم لا ابدا يا عزيزتي
ابدا اولا كل القوه السياسيه لا تمانع في
الجلوس مع المكونا العسكري ما عدا مركزيه
الحريه والتغيير والحزب السياسي فقط هؤلاء
الذين كانوا يرفعوا الايات الثلاثه لكن
بغيت كل الغور السياسيه لا مانع لديها من
ان تجلس مع المكاينه العسكري في اي مكان
وفي اي وقت ال- ال- ال- ال- ال- الموضوع
الان القوات المسلحه غدا والتنازلات كبيره
جدا في سبيل اخراج البلاد من هذه الازمه
المركزيه الحريه تغيير نعم نشكر لها ايضا
متنازلات وردت بان تجلس وتتحاور لكن يجب
عليها ان تغير خطابه يعني لا يمكن ان ن ن
ونحن نتحدث عن اخراج البلاد من هذه الازمه
ان اتحدث عن قوه الثوره وقوه الانتقال
هؤلاء الاساس وهؤلاء التوابع هذا كلام غير
مقبول الشيء الاخر يجب ما كن ما دام كنا
نريد ان نخرج بهذه البلاد من الازمه يجب
ان نتواضع وان نجلس مع بقيه القوى وما
دامت هذه الوثيقه مطروحه للتعديل
ليس ليس هنالك ما يمنع بقيه الغوع من ان
تاتي وتجلس وتدخل اغلامها وتعديلاتها في
هذه الوزيره مادام كانت هذه التعديلات
لمصلحه الوطن ولل ولم يسم للقوه السواريه
نحن لا نقول اغراغ المشهد همم السياسي بكل
همم المكونات ولكن نقول كل الذين شاركوا
في صلاه النظام يجب ان يكون حضوره هذا
التفاهم الذي تم بمركزيه الحريه والتغيير
والقوات المسلحه تضمن قوه التوريه همم
كبيره موجوده في الساحه لكن في الواقع لم
نجدها يعني هنالك همم الحريه والتغيير
التوافق الوطني الحسبه الاتحاد الاصل همم
انصار السنه المؤتمر الشعبي هؤلاء حتى
عندما من رايناه منه رايناهم يضعوه في
خانه التابع وليس الاصيل في هذا الاجراء
نحن نعتقد ان كل هذه القوه قوه اصيله يجب
كلها ان تجلس في مائده واحده وهي كل سنه
واحد من اجل ان يخرج البلاد لكن اذا كنا
نجري وراء المحاصصه وراء المناصي وراء ان
ان ان ان نمرن اجندات من خلال الفتره
الانتقاليه على حساب الاخرين
100 سنه
تحول السيد همم الصديق نتسائل حقيقه كمان
المشاهد الكريم هل هذه الوثيقه وما جاء
فيها هي نادعه من من مكونات همم اصيله
واصليه همم
السودان سواء طبقه سياسيه او حتى من
العسكريين اما انها كان ما يلمز البعض
نتاج ل همم يعني
صورت من الخارج وهو خارجيه اقليميه وحتى
دوليه هي التي تصيغه
وفق ربما مصالحها وليس بالضروره مصالح
الشعب السودانيه
انا ابدا من الوثيقه
المشروع الدستور الانتقالي مساله الدوره
الاجنبي ام هو مجهود وطني
والمشاركه التي كانت فيه هو مجهود وطني
خالص
قوه سياسيه ومدنيه ومهنيه وشبابيه ال- اا
كانت جزء من هذا النقاش في ورشه وعده
عدتها اللجنه التسيريه لانقاذه المحامين
ورشه مفتوحه ومحضوره من الجميع حاولت بعد
القوه التي لا تريد الاستقرار لا تريد
للسودانيين تحول مدني ديمقراطي حاولت ان
تهاجم الورشه وتصدع اهل الورشه لهم
واستمرت الورشه واخرجت يعني همم
مخرجاتها وتوصياتها ومين بعد ذلك تكون
لجان لل- همم
للتوفيات والصياغه
شاركت مكونات عديده واسعه ومعروفه نشرت
التسييريه كل الذين شاركوا من قوه سياسيه
واسعه تتجاوز الحريه والتغيير كثيرا وال
شارك فيها الحسبه الاتحاد الاصل والمؤتمر
الشعبي وانصار سنن المحمديه من القوه
السياسيه وشاركت قوه مهنيه وكذلك قوه
شبابيه كل هذه المشاركه همم ولجنه همم تم
الاتفاق عليها للصياغه
كانت فيها مشاركه واسعه تمثل كل الاطراف
وكذلك لجنه خبراء سودانيه تمت استشاراتهم
خبراء في اعداد الدساتير ولجنه خبراء
خارجيه تمت استشاراتهم من المنظمات التي
تعمل على اعداد الدساتير وليس فرض الرؤى
والاراء كل هذه تاسست على الرؤى ومخرجات
الورشه
هذه الدول
هذه الوثيقه النقطه التي اشار اليها
الفريق الاول فتح الرحمن مهمه جدا في ما
يخص العداله الانتقاليه ان وجهه نظركم
انتم في الموضوع هل ستقدمون ضمانات بشان
عدم ملاحقه العسكريين المتهمين بارتكاب
انتهاكات في حق السودانيين
طيب تمام انا اكمل ما كنت اقوله في هذا
الجانب من ان التشاور كانوا واسعا في
المشروع الدستور
ال ال وكانوا وطنيا
ليست هناك محاصه وما تقوم به الحريه
والتغيير همم لم تستعسر ولا باستطاعتها ان
تستاثر باي شيء في حوارها وتفهماتها مع
القيادات العسكريه انما هي تتحدث عن تحقيق
اهداف الثوره وسلطه مدنيه والذين يرون هذه
المخرجات والتي تاسست على مشروع الدستور
الانتقالي كل الكلام هذا ليس فيه سطر واحد
يقول ان القوه الحريه والتغيير
بنفسها على هذا الشيء او ذاك ان التمييز
الذي يعني جاء في اختيار ال- ال- الاجهزه
الحكم المدني همم لقوه الثوره منطقه واضح
نحن نتحدث عن سلطه مد الذين هم ليسوا من
قوه الثوره هم مواطنون سودانيون لهم حق
المشاركه ولكن في المراحل السابقه لهذا
العمل الذي نطلع به الان هم ما عندهم قشه
مره كمان نقول هنا في ال- ال- ال- الحكم
الشمولي ولا يطلبون حكم او سلطه مدنيه
وهذا هو الفارق الجوهري لهم حق المشاركه
في قضايا مختلفه في الدستور في
المجلس التشريعي وامه في السلطه
يعني اتحول الفريق اول فتح الرحمن محي
الدين يعني همم بهذه الانقسامات الموجوده
في القوى المدنيه والتي تعيبونها عليهم
بشكل كبير يعني هناك ما نتحدث ايضا على ان
المؤسسه العسكريه ايضا ليست على قلبي رجل
واحد هل همم هناك همم ربما اجماع بين
مختلف قاده ايش ودعم السريع على الاجهزه
الامنيه على شروط تولي المدنيين للحكم هل
هناك رؤيه واضحه واجنده واضحه وواحده
للجميع تحت المظله العسكريه
النظاميه على قلب رجل واحد وكلها متوافقه
وانا يعني اقول لك يعني حتى هذه الوزيره
التي ادخلت عليها التعديلات ااه نحن لا
نتحدث الان من اين اتت لكن ما يهمنا فيها
يجب ان تخدم المصلحه الوطنيه
همم اتخلته القوات المسلحه من التعديلات
فيها كان فيه كثير من التنازلات حتى
تتوافق القوه العسكريه فيما بينها حتى
تكون على قلبي رجل واحد وتكون كلمتها واحد
ادخلت هذه التعديلات وردت بهذه الوثيقه ان
تكون اساسا
للقوه السياسيه الاخرى معدلته القوات
المسلحه مهيله القوات المسلحه يبقى على
القوه المدنيه ان تجلس وتعدل مايليها حتى
تكون هذه هي اساس التواصل لكن انا واكد
عزيزتي اذا كان المنطق الذي يتحدث عنه
السيد الصديق في ان همم قوه الثوره هي
التي ستختار رئيس الوزراء وهي التي ستشكل
الحكومه نعتقد ان التسويه وين تمت فلن
تحقق استقرار في السودان ولم تخرج البلاد
من هذه الازمه
دعوه الى مائده مستديره تجلس مركزيته هو
الحريه والتغيير مع الوفاق الوطني مع
الاحزابلان
الحزب الاتحاد
السنه المؤتمر الشعبي همم الحريه والتغيير
الوفاق الوطني الاحزاب التي كانت على
الغاز اتت الى توافق مع الناس من خلال
اتفاقيه سلام هؤلاء كلهم عندما يجلسوا انا
اعتقد هذا هو قطاع واسع من الشعب يمكن من
خلاله
تتحدث معك في نقطه اخرى
لدينا العديد من نقاط السيد الفريق الاول
يعني المشهد سوداني بعد قناه اكتوبر
وعناصر المؤتمر الوطني المنحل نظمه ايضا
مظاهره همم تتهم قوات الامن بالتعاطف معها
ما تفسير ذلك ما حقيقه العلاقه في الواقع
بين العسكريين والقوه الاسلاميه وعلى
راسها المؤتمر الوطني
لا علاقه للعسكريين بالمؤتمر الوطني ولا
علاقه للعسكريين بالاسلاميين هذه
التظاهرات عزيزتي ليست مظاهرات المؤتمر
الوطني هذه مظاهرات نداء السودان دعا
اليها الشيخ الطيب الجد ومعروف هذا رجل
صوفي لا علاقه له بالاسلام السياسي رجل
صوفي دعا الى ان لم شمل الشعب السوداني
انا اعتقد الان هنالك قطاع واسع جدا تحت
رايه الشيخ الطيب جدا لكننا ايضا نقول
لمركزيه الحريه والتغيير دعو هؤلاء
توافقوا مع الاخرين هذا قطع واسع جدا وانا
اكد لكي يمكن يمثل الغالبيه الغالبيه
الشعب السوداني لكن ايضا نقول لمركزيه
الحريه والتغيير
بانهم اسلاميون ضيفوهم
اتركوهم تواضعوا مع الاخرين مركز
حتى مع الاخرين لا تريد ان تتوافق لا
تاريخ لا تريد ان تتوافق مع توافق الوطني
الاصيل في اسقاط النظام لا تريد ان تتوافق
مع الذين تنا اما بديعهم وجلسوا مع الحريه
والتغيير من انصار السنه والمؤتمر الشعبي
ورددوا بان يكونوا جزء من العمليه
السياسيه لا تريد لهم ان يكونوا اصيلين
تريد انهم يكونوا توابع
وتموم الجرتي كما يقول المثال عندنا في
السودان وهذا غير مقبول وهذا ان تم لن
يحقق استغرار الاستماره
الدوله السودانيه الوثيقه التي كنا نتحدث
عنها تنص على ان السودان دوله مدنيه تقف
على النفس المسافه من كل الاديان هل تخلى
حزب الامه عن مرجعته الدينيه وهو يعني كما
هو معروف حزب ديرتك تاريخيا على الارث
الديني للثوره المهديه
حزب الام اصلا متفق على ان لا تؤثر
الاحزاب السياسيه على اساس ديني هذا هو
منهج الامه وفي ما يلي ما تم الاتفاق عليه
في كل محتويات الدستور كانت فيها مشاركات
واسعه
وكل هذه المحتويات حقيقه هي يعني ترتيبات
الدستور في المرحله الانتقاليه التي نحن
نتحدث عن سنتين
عقد المتفق على قيام المؤتمر الدستوري
الذي يناقش كل قضايا الحكم وكل القضايا
الخلافيه وكل القضايا الدستوريه بمشاركه
واسعه من كل الذين لهم راي وروى
يريدون وضعها في الدستور الدائم للبلاد
وكذلك سيتفخ
المؤتمر الدستوري على همم
يعني التشاور والمشهور الشعبيه في الدستور
همم سواء كانت عبر الاستفتاء او اي اهليه
يتفق عليها في المؤتمر الدستوري ولذلك همم
اريد ان اقول هنا همم الذين يعني يتحدثون
عن هذا الجانب همم
الحريصون على الحريات والحرفون على
العداله وحرصون هؤلاء جميعهم يجدونه
انفسهم في هذا الدستور عدد من القوه التي
تحتاج بهذا الجانب انما تحتاج في حقيقه
الامر على التمكين الذي فقدته وهي انما
ترفع الرايه همم محاوله التبني رايه
الاسلام ولكنها في حقيقه الامر ضربت
الاسلام في مقتل في السودان بانها ولدت
الحريات وردت العداله وممارسه الظلم
والعدوان والانتاج والقتل والاباده والنهب
الموارد همم واستنزافتها عبر التمكين الذي
اقيم في البلاد ولذلك هذه حجه واحده التي
ديت يذكرونها الان التباقي على الاسلام
والتباكي على الوطنيه والسياده الوطنيه
والدور التدخل الاجنبي هم عبرهم وعبر
الحكم الشمول القابض اتى بالتدخل الاجنبي
للبلاد وسلمه مفاصل الدوله في جوانب كثيره
نحن بالسلطه المدنيه وبالتوسيع المشاوره
والمشاركه وبي التوجه الى التحول المدني
الديمقراطي الذي نزع له الان انما نريد
تامين البلاد من التدخلات الاجنبيه وحفظ
سيادتها وان يسود الرايه السوداني عبر
الحكم المدني والتحول الديمقراطي اتحول
اليك مره اخرى الفريق اول فتح الرحمن يعني
همم من بين النقاط ايضا التي اكد عليها
العسكريون انهم مع اصلاح القوات المسلحه
وهذه النقطه بالذات هي محل نقاش وجدل كبير
في اوساط السودانيين الميزانيه الجيش هناك
من يريد ان تدخل في اطار الموازنه همم
العامه يعني همم فرص اخداعها بالفعل
الحكومه المدنيه ما الذي يمكن ان يقال في
هذا الموضوع
واصلاح المنظومه العسكريه يعني تم التوافق
عليه في هذه الوسيله التي نتحدث عنها في
انه مسؤوليه القوات المسلحه فيما يتعلق
بالله الشركات التي تتبع للقوات النظاميه
هنالك اتفاق تم منذ زمن الحكومه الدكتور
عبد الله حمدون ان ال- ال- المصانع
والهيئات التي صبغه عسكريه تظل كما هي
تتبع للقوات المسلحه الشركات ذات الصبغه
الاقتصاديه همم تطرح تطرح في سوء الاوراق
الماليه كاسهم ويساهم فيها المكون المدني
وهذا الامر اعتقد انه تمت معالجته منذ زمن
الدكتور عبد الله عنده ايضا ان يعني كلمه
الحق التي يراد بها باطل الحديث المضلل
الذي ذكر الدكتور عبد الله حمدان بانه
هنالك اكثر من 80% من ميزانيه الدوله بعيد
القوات المسلحه ايضا هذا حديث يعني
الخبراء الاقتصاديين همم في الندوه عزبه
منه هذا حديث غير صحيح كل هذه الشركات
التي تعمل في المجال الاقتصادي تحت النظر
لا تتجاوز ال 5% من
الميزانيه الدوله يعني فهذا حديث كان غير
دقيق من الدكتور عبدالله حمدون قصد قصد
منه تضليل يعني
انتهى تماما
الاخر صديق يقول حديث جميل ولكنهم في
الواقع لا يطبقوه يعني يتحدث عن توسيع
قعده وهم يبلغوه بعد المشاركه الحريه
والتغيير حزب البعثه خارج منها يعني
فرصه قادمه ان شاء الله لمواصلت هذا
الحديث الفريق الاول فتح الرحمن المحيدين
القائد العام السابق للقوات البحريه
السودانيه اشكرك جزيلا شكرا كما اشكر
جزيلا شكرا السيد الصديق الصادق المهدي
مساعد رئيس حزب الامه الناطق باسم المجلس
المركزي للحريه
والتغيير بين الكلمات من الخرطوم
باذن الله مع بقيه لقصه جديده الاثنين
القادم ان شاء الله سلام عليكم
[موسيقى]